president Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
is calling James Comey a quote
disgraceful liar he said the fired FBI
director who used to work for Giuliani
should be prosecuted this echoes earlier
statements made by the president commis
new memoir a higher loyalty truth lies
and leadership is now a New York Times
bestseller it chronicles his early
career his years in the Justice
Department and his relationship with
President Trump James Comey good morning
well morning great to be with you your
book talks about your early career and
the first time you met Rudy Giuliani
we're very excited to go work for him
you said it fired me up working for him
so this guy who got you fired up is now
saying pretty tough things about you
yeah it seems like the love is gone I
enjoyed working for him as a young
prosecutor
I found him exciting and brash I learned
through the lens of adulthood that
wasn't a great kind of leadership but it
was an exciting place to be a young
prosecutor but what about his claims
that you should be prosecuted you know
he's essentially echoing what the
president has said he leaked information
that you I mean he's a people he has a
lot of authority with a lot of people
yeah we're lucky to live in a country
where facts matter and that people
aren't prosecuted by people tweeting
about them and so the facts in this case
there just make those accusations
ridiculous he also called FBI agents who
raided Michael Cohen's office he
compared them to stormtroopers Nazis
Nazi Germany you sort of deflect when he
attacks you what is your reaction when
he's going after FBI agents calling them
stormtroopers yeah that's unacceptable
when our nation's leaders the president
or his representatives attack the
institutions of Justice the rest of us
have to not only pay attention we have
to speak out because we need those
institutions and the notion that the FBI
is made up of Nazi storm troopers it's
just wrong and dangerous and so I I
think all of us have to say that's not
normal that's not okay and speak back to
it there's and isn't this book James
Comey your way of speaking out and
drawing attention to say to the people
that listen it's not normal what's
happening in the White House is not
normal and we've got to figure out a way
to stop this and correct it isn't that
what you're doing in part I mean I think
what I can do is make a small
contribution by asking
questions about what matters and what
unites us which is our values and we're
losing track of and becoming numb to the
erosion of our core values of truth than
the rule of law no but you say the
president is unethical untethered to the
truth institutional values his
leadership is transactional ego driven
and about personal loyalty and some
people are raising that those exact
things about you people can say whatever
they want Mike might what I hope people
will do is not get caught down in the
back-and-forth of Twitter personnel and
personal conflicts but ask themselves
what unites us in this country the truth
the rule of law equal protection of the
laws and it's not okay for the President
of the United States to attack those
things and to routinely lie no matter
what your politics it's just not okay
aside from the President of the United
States you also said that you lost trust
and leadership at the DOJ starting with
Jeff Sessions and in broad Rosenstein
I'm curious as to whether any of that
trust has come back given some of their
actions as of late rod Rosen side said
the DOJ won't be extorted Jeff Sessions
reportedly said that he would be that he
would resign if rod Rosen Stein was
fired do you find that reassuring I do
I was critical of them when I thought
they were acting in a way that was not
consistent with the values of the
department I think since then especially
the Deputy Attorney General has acted
consistent with those values and
protected the rule of law can I pull us
away from abstractions for a moment you
talk about values and ethical leadership
but that's what your book is really
about a lot of it's been missed in the
cut and thrust what does this mean day
to day if you're a young FBI
investigator how does this trickle down
to the day to day job you do the
maintenance of those values well making
sure the American people understand the
nature of your work as an FBI agent and
that you should be trusted is that the
core of your effectiveness when you
knock on a door and promise a sexual
assault victim you'll protect her
identity it's important that she
believes you or that when a jury hears
that you found something in a car it's
important that they believe you so that
you can do the good that you do every
day for the country that's why the
attacks on the institution are so
dangerous because we all need these
institutions what about what keeps an
FBI agent who's working by themselves
might be encouraged to cut a corner
how do these values help from that end
in terms of instilling them with with
the values that guide their work well
they know two things in the FBI and
they're trained from the very beginning
values are at the center of the
organization and if there's a deviation
from those values there will be severe
accountability you see that all the time
in the Justice Department and the FBI we
hold our people accountable to those
values Time magazine has a piece
entitled the FBI is in crisis and it's
worse than do you think do you think
that this public spat with the President
and your role at all has contributed to
this internal crisis that Time magazine
is talking about sure in in the sense
that I had to make decisions over the
last year we were stuck in the middle of
these situations both the Hillary
Clinton email investigation and with
respect to President Trump they were
incredibly difficult that there were no
good options and so anytime you're stuck
there the institution and you are going
to take a hit when you have talked about
your own time at the FBI you said you
wish you had maybe pushback with
attorney general Loretta Lynch you also
said in that meeting with the white with
the president you wish you'd done things
differently
reflecting on those two instances and
what you would ask people to do now
under President Trump do you see how
people might not be able to stand up and
take the kind of action you you've got
you're kind of calling for in terms of
calling out the president I do and it's
not easy especially when you're alone
with the president in the Oval Office
but one of the things I hope to do is
remind people we have to because
whatever our vigorous policy
disagreements our values are all we have
and if our leaders and the people they
leave don't recognize that and stand up
for those values who are we as a country
if you write in the book that at times
you were concerned about your own ego
that maybe you had blinders on and
couldn't look at other people's point of
view that you don't like being
criticized nobody does but that you pay
attention to your critics what have you
learned from the criticism you've
received because you managed to piss
this off tick up tick off people on both
sides
Democrats and Republicans wherever you
go people have something negative to say
about you what have you learned from
your critics you have a lot of support
too but what have you learned from your
critics it's mostly in my family but no
your wife is your wife is definitely a
big supporter I loved reading
the start is amazing but what I've
learned is that sometimes the way I see
myself is not the way reasonable
thoughtful people see me and you can't
get trapped in that view that that
everyone will understand what's inside
my head and accept my good motivations
except that I'm acting in the right way
and I blew a number of things that I
talked about in the book and a lot of
them were based on perception where I
didn't anticipate how people might hear
my words differently than I intended
them if you were interviewing the
president what would you ask him well
I'd ask him if I were Bob Muller I'd ask
him a whole lot of questions and I would
want as much time as I needed to be able
to conduct a competent investigation
interview how much time would that it
would all depend upon how
straightforward the witness was and
whether the witness answer the questions
questions like what because we know
you'd ask a lot of questions you can
hear your top two questions that you
want to know well you certainly looking
at the question of obstruction of
justice we want to understand what his
State of Mind was around things like his
conversation with me on Valentine's Day
I have one view of that but I don't know
what was in his head and that's critical
to the question of obstruction so you'd
want to know what were you thinking and
why do you say that and who did you talk
to about that tell me why that helps
because if you were asking me that
question I would say well I do I wasn't
trying to obstruct anything Rudy
Giuliani he said you wouldn't tell the
president he was in the clear and that
that was grounds enough for him to fire
you since he's essentially your boss
well you'd want to ask follow-up
questions based on the other
investigation that you've done the
reason you interview a subject towards
the end of the investigation as we did
with Hillary Clinton is you've gathered
all kinds of facts documents other
people's recollections that you can use
to test what that subject says to you
one of the things really Giuliani says
is you told her Laurie Clinton she was
in the clear why couldn't you have said
that publicly about President Trump we
completed the investigation of Secretary
Clinton and announced its completion
there's an ongoing investigation near as
I can tell and I don't know how the
special counsel will approach it but
they're two very different things next
week though rather will be a year since
the firing we all remember watching it
on TV it was painful to watch and it was
a painful day for you and in this in
that past year you've had time to
reflect what are you thinking now James
Comey about how you've handled yourself
in the last year what you see
for yourself going forward where are you
now I am looking backwards proud of the
work that the FBI has done we really did
act consistent with our values have a
great sense of pain over a lot that's
going on especially our being stuck in
the middle of the election but I'm at
peace with the decisions we made I keep
saying we because I'm accountable for
the decisions but it was a large group
of talented people who made those-- and
I'm a happy person despite a lot of the
rocks thrown and I'm gonna teach
starting in the fall which would be
really cool because young people talk
about holding you accountable
it'll be stimulating James come me thank
you so much for joining thanks really do
you I know we're your last TV interview
I'd like to think you saved the best for
last certainly do really good to meet
you thank you all and say hi to your
wife I will thank you a higher loyalty
is on sale now wherever you'd like to
buy your book